so like the two i found that basically
the best paper to use
for sandwiching two sheets together was
bible paper
um it's really really thin
and opaque
to where you could uh
you know
print the front of a bill in the back of
a bill and then on the back of the back
print a strip and a watermark
and then um
like mist on a little bit of gorilla
glue spray
squeegee
together you know i had a piece of glass
with led lights behind it so you could
see through the bills to line everything
up
wow squeegee them together and then i
found
the
the counterfeit pens are a a chemical
reaction so so when you test a bill
it's a iodine-based ink so the iodine in
the in the ink reacts to starch in the
paper which turns it the black thing
so real money it stays yellow you know
what i mean and counterfeits will stay
black so
i figured out that uh spraying the bills
with a lacquer spray it's basically like
clear spray paint a matte lacquer
basically created a barrier
you know and prevented the chemical
reaction between the pen and the in the
paper you know i mean
so um and i'd tweak things here and
there and find different methods that
worked significantly well
like once you glue the bills together
if you if you spray a thick coat
first
to make sure that the counterfeit pens
don't you know
react with the starch in the paper
and then let that dry and then spray
another coat from a distance it kind of
mists on and it gives it a texture
um
so like
basically and i'd sometimes iron iron
the bills just a little bit to make them
nice and crispy and you know rigid
and
i found uh
this iridescent green eyeshadow
which is basically just a color shifting
pigment that they sell as makeup um
and i could
take uh it's like a shader pen which is
an invisible ink pen
and dip it in the the eyeshadow and
color on the little color shifting 100
in the corner um
and uh
there was uh in visit they've got
invisible ink uv pens
which like
are basically marketed to like little
girls diaries you know i mean you can
write in the diary and nobody can read
it and then you shine the black light in
it so i found those in red ink
so i'd uh take a ruler over where the
strip is and draw a line that way if if
anybody put the bills in a black light
the strip would appear to to glow red as
well
so i knew like with all those features
uh beat
you know there's really no way that
anyone could prove that these bills were
fake if they even suspected it you know
what i mean because it marks with the
pen it's got the strip and the watermark
in it color shifting ink it glows in the
back light the only way that
really you could tell is if you put it
in a machine to check the magnetic ink
like a bill validator
or money counters at banks
so by the time the bills hit the bank
the bank would discover they were fake
but at that point i you know it would be
a week later nobody on the street could
ever find out
no i've had bankers at one time i went
to a chinese food restaurant
and uh went to break it and it was this
little chinese woman she like
she was holding it up and she wasn't
sure so she she
one of her regular customers was a
banker and he was sitting over there so
she had he's like okay is this bill real
and gave it to him and he he said it was
real
so
i've had a drug deal i mean one drug
dealer i uh
i
gave him a bill and told him that they
were fake i was like you know you want
to start buying these from me he didn't
believe me that that you know that they
were fake because once they mark with i
mean everybody just marks it with a pen
or
you know holds it up to look for a strip
or a watermark or you know what i mean
what does that actually do when they
mark them with the pen
basically it's uh so it's a ink in the
pen that's iodine based okay that iodine
reacts with starch
so all paper is treated with starch
except for you know currency money okay
so if you if you mark any any regular
paper it'll mark black because the
iodine reacts with that starch and turns
black whereas real money doesn't
so it stays yellow so it's just a way to
you know depends are
you know to detect counterfeit currency
but like i said i i would spray my bills
with a lacquer that's what the lacquer
did yeah so when you go to mark the
paper you're really not touching the
paper because there's a clear coat of
lacquer over it to separate the the pen
from the paper okay
um
it seems like a a very intricate process
and a long a long process like
how like when you started doing this at
scale like printing thousands and
thousands of dollars like i can't
imagine what like how would your process
change like you're doing this with bible
paper stuff yeah um
and like the hardest part was acquiring
the bible paper really i would take road
trips
all up the east coast pretty much to go
to cities to go to bookstores and rip
out blank pages because the bible has
like anywhere from two to twenty blank
pages in the back usually
so you know if you go into a barnes
noble or bookstore or whatever and open
a bible and i just have a little razor
knife and cut 10 blank pages out
do that over and over again
so say if there's five blank pages in
each bible and you're in a bookstore
with a hundred bibles you know i mean
that's 500 pages
which is you know you could make 25 50
grand off of one bookstore wow
so i mean it got to the point where
eventually i'd already been to every
bookstore in knoxville chattanooga
atlanta up to lexington cleveland holy
[ __ ]
but
um
yeah so i was basically selling i wanted
to just sell these bills to to people
and not use them no i did i was nervous
you know i mean because like i knew like
i would constantly
uh you know analyze these bills always
try and make them better and you know i
mean but you kind of get in your head
you wonder like i think they look good
but you sit there and look at something
all day every day you wonder if you know
you're paying attention to the finest
details exactly you see everything
that's wrong with them probably right
yeah so
the first time i went i i think
for whatever reason i just grew the
balls walked into a taco bell and she
held it up and boom cast it no problem
so i was
okay you know
they kind of started doing more shopping
sprees you know i mean you hit up a
couple more places they take it no
problem every other time they they'd
either mark it with the pen or hold it
up a couple people sometimes would you
know analyze it a little bit but like i
said there's
every feature is beat i mean the bills
looked pretty much perfect you know i
mean i changed all the serial numbers
on each bill that way you never had more
than one bill with the same serial
number
um
you know so
and there's different uh
different ways to like do it without
getting caught obviously you know you
park in like a parking lot over here
and you know walk a few hundred feet
just so no cameras in the parking lot
can maybe get your license plate or
whatever
so you might park in
one section over here and then like walk
to a mall or an area with lots of
businesses and you could just hit up you
know each business so yeah that was way
more profitable than i mean i also sold
them too
but you know for ten thousand dollars i
could sell it for 2500 or i could just
go spend ten thousand dollars okay you
know so once i got the confidence like
yeah these are all passing no problem
uh you know i started doing both
okay just selling them to multiple drug
dealers throughout knoxville
um it's buying prepaid visa cards
getting money orders oh wow you know
what i mean
if i found like a prepaid visa cards
have like a three dollar fee added on to
it so
if you get a hundred dollar prepaid visa
card it'll be like a hundred and three
dollars a hundred four dollars so you
give them two hundred dollar bills and
you get ninety five dollars change and a
hundred dollar prepaid visa card and if
you go to like a walmart and hit up like
the electronic center register the
garden center and couple registers up
front i mean you're making a thousand
dollars just for that you know that one
walmart and i just hit up stores like
that all day every day for years
[Laughter]